good morning believe nation today's
message is collaborate with others over
to you gabe newell you're testing your
ideas you're stimulating each other
that's what what makes us successful
it's not some flash of brilliance by
somebody who then codes 24 hours a day
for three weeks it's what happened the
magic happens when we're all on the same
page collaborating and building
something together if you don't
collaborate with other people the
opportunity for you to make an impact is
going to be limited and as entrepreneurs
sometimes we want to do everything
ourselves and I know in the past he may
have been burned you may have tried to
hire an employee and it didn't work out
or a couple employees and put in all the
training in time and effort and money
and it didn't work out or maybe had a
business partner or a couple business
partners in a failed venture and that
didn't work out and so the natural
inclination is to retreat inside and try
to do everything yourself and that's the
safe easy thing to do and it's always
going to limit your success you have to
understand it if you want to have a big
impact you want to make a lot of money
you want to build a big business it has
to be by collaborating with other people
I like to think of it in terms of dating
right so when you date you know you may
not it may not work out your first date
and so you date other people may be
multiple people until you find somebody
that works out if you get married you
may find that that marriage didn't work
out and so is the right response to then
just give up and be by yourself the rest
of your life no to get back on the horse
and try to find that right person for
you and so if you want to have a big
impact with your business if you want to
have big success if you want to reach
the goals that you set for yourself you
have to understand that you can't do
everything yourself you are great at
doing some things and you should go all
in on those things and collaborate with
other people to help round out your
weaknesses believe so my question the
day for you is I want to know what the
best collaboration you've ever had in
your business has been leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you guys for watching
have an amazing day
can you to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso I works espresso keep me
going